hello and welcome i'm james murphy from mcoding.io
where i offer nine week weekend programming
courses today brownian motion if you're watching
this video you've probably heard of brownian
motion before but the purpose of this video is
not so much to tell you what brownie emotion is
but rather to give you a way to simulate it so
that you can play with it yourself surprisingly
simulating brownian motion is actually not that
difficult i've already imported numpy for doing
some of the math operations and matplotlib for
plotting the first thing that i'm going to do
is define the number of time steps that i want
to use and my time horizon so this means that
i'm going to be simulating brownian motion from
time 0 to time 1 and i'm going to do so using 10
000 sample points next we'll use numpy.linspace
to make the set of times that we're going to use
so linspace takes the initial time the final time
and the number of sample points just for your
benefit let's go ahead and print out times with
a small number of time steps so you can see what
it's doing you can see it's just going in uniform
increments zero up until one continuing on i think
the next thing that we're going to need is what is
the time step that is between each of those times
so we'll just take times of one minus times of
zero the next thing that we need to figure out is
how do we actually get values of the brownian
motion well almost the characterizing property
of brownian motion is its independent normally
distributed increments what that means is that
if i have brownian motion at some time t2 and
i subtract brownian motion at some time t1 well
then this is a random variable and it's normally
distributed with mean zero and variance t2 minus
t1 so instead of trying to find a single formula
for the brownian motion i'll just generate all of
these normally distributed increments and then add
them up so let's make db meaning the increments
of brownian motion the differences between the
values of the brownian motion that will be a
numpy random normal and let's give
it a shape or size which is equal to
we're going to need the number of time steps
minus 1 because the first one is always going
to be zero brownian motion starts at zero then
we need n minus one for the rest of time steps
so by default this is going to give me mean
zero variance one and what i need is variance dt
because we're looking at increments of the
brownian motion which are in times in this
array all of those times consecutive times in
that array are separated by a distance of dt
from each other so in order to get a variance of
dt i'll need to multiply by the square root of dt
so let's just do that numpy square root of dt
times that so db now is an array of differences
of values of brownian motion we still haven't
constructed any of the values yet just their
differences to get the actual values of brownian
motion we'll need to start with its value at zero
and then cumulatively add up the differences so
brownian motion starts at zero so let's just use
numpy.zeros to create the array and it takes
a shape parameter and we're just gonna have
one zero for now later on we're going to be
generalizing to simulating multiple brownian
motions or equivalently a single multi-dimensional
browning motion so if you don't understand why
we're choosing to make this zero an array instead
of just a scalar just keep that in mind that we're
going to be generalizing in a little bit to
get the actual values of the brownian motion
we just need to concatenate the initial value
with the cumulative sum of the increments so
i'll take these things to be concatenated let's
take b0 and the cumulative sum of the increments
and then we can go ahead and just plot it so we'll
plot that x values are the times and the y values
are the brownian motion and
then we'll show the plot
so if we did everything correctly then
we should see a plot of brownian motion
all right that looks pretty good to me one
thing that i do want to test is i just want to
make sure that if we used less time points that
we're still getting the right thing so i do see
that it starts at zero and it's going around
the value minus one of course it's random but
the values that you get for brownian motion
shouldn't depend on the number of sample points
but only on the time horizon so if i go out to
t equals one it shouldn't matter if i take 10
000 sample points i should still have something
which is around the range plus or minus one and
you can see even though it's a totally different
sample path different number of sample points
we do end up around one now of course it's
possible that that doesn't happen but it's just
the most likely thing is to be in that range minus
one to one if you did this experiment and you
found that when you increase the number of sample
points that the value of your brownian motion was
increasing then you probably would have messed
up the scaling so for instance if i delete this
proper scaling by square root of t and then
run the simulation again so here you can see
that by time one uh we're getting values that
are up at like 80 and down to minus 50 almost
minus 60. so if you see that that should be your
clue that brownie motion doesn't move that much in
that amount of time so if that happens check your
scaling i'll go ahead and put the proper scaling
back in there okay so that's one brownian motion
what if we want to increase the number of samples
let's introduce a new parameter d which is
the number of brownian motions that we're
going to simulate all at once so for now
let's just have say five brownian motions
so how can we modify this now our times are not
going to change because they're all living on
the same time axis since our times didn't change
our dt doesn't change either the first thing that
actually changes is going to be the increments so
instead of being normally distributed with this
size now we need to just add in a d here the first
coordinate is going to be our time coordinate and
the second coordinate is going to be our either
space coordinate if you're thinking of it as a
multi-dimensional brownian motion or the index of
the brownian motion if you're thinking about it
as a bunch of independent one-dimensional brownian
motions which is how it will be drawn when we plot
it of course now the initial value of the brownian
motion is going to be 1 by d because there are
d components of it now oh and by the way if you
wanted to consider a brownian motion that's not
started at 0 this is exactly where you would
change it you just put in the numbers that you
want there and then you'll get samples of
your brownian motion started at that place
there are two things that we need to change on
this line namely now that our db has more than one
dimension to it we need to specify when we do the
cumulative sum and when we do the concatenation
what axis we're doing that over so i know that i
want to sum in time not in space so i want to sum
at the zero axis not the one axis so let's change
the cumulative sum to axis equals zero and let's
change the concatenation axis to axis equals zero
again that's because i again want to concatenate
b0 on as the first time step not as a spatial
dimension then we can go ahead and plot it again
so there you have it it looks like we have a good
five samples of brownian motion going just for
fun let's bump up the number of brownian motions
and see what it looks like when we do a hundred
if you've never seen a picture like
this i would encourage you to sit
and stare at it for a while
it's a little bit mesmerizing
even though our brownian motion was made up of
totally independent increments every single one
was just randomly generated we're starting to see
some structure here even with a hundred sample
paths there's a clear shape that's emerging where
the brownian motion really tends to not go outside
of that shape let me bump it up to a thousand here
just so we can get a little bit better picture of
that shape now we see a very defined shape with
just a few outliers out of a thousand samples we
have almost a parabolic shape that's emerging if
you're interested in learning about this property
it's actually a very well known fact you should
look up what's called the law of the iterated
logarithm for brownian motion it tells you that
brownian motion really tends not to exceed about
square root of 2t and from the name you can guess
that there's a logarithm or 2 hiding in there
but that's not for this video this just shows that
by simulating you can gain a lot of insight into
the statistical properties of a kind of random
process like brownian motion the last thing that
i wanted to show you is another key insight
that you can see just by simulating like this
another characteristic factor of brownian
motion it has so many interesting properties but
one of them is its quadratic variation now the
quadratic variation isn't something that you would
probably come up in a video just about brownian
motion it's more of something that you can look
at for a general stochastic process and it just
turns out to have a very interesting formula
when you put in brownian motion the quadratic
variation is not a whole lot more than what
it sounds like basically we're just going
to take differences of the brownian motion
square them and add them so let's take the
numpy difference of the brownian motion
along the axis zero because remember zero was
for time and to preserve the original dimensions
of the brownian motion i'll just go ahead and
prepend zero because the quadratic variation
is something that's defined just like brownian
motion to start at zero then i'll take those
differences and raise them to the power two then
i will again use the cumulative sum function
so that i can graph them and again we'll do this
along axis 0 that's the time axis and then i will
just return it if you didn't quite follow the
formulas and dimensions that went into this
just consider the case where d equals one then
all the axis stuff disappears and what you end
up having is basically look at the differences
of the brownian motion take them to the power two
and add them up so now instead of plotting
b let's plot the quadratic variation of b
huh that's weird when you see this picture you
might think that i've done something wrong just
to be sure that i haven't accidentally messed up
the brownian in motion somehow let's go ahead and
plot again just throw that original plot of b back
in so you can see the brownian motion is still
wiggling all over the place it has all of the
same properties that we were talking about before
but yet this quadratic variation looks like just a
line and indeed that is the case the property that
i was alluding to earlier is that the quadratic
variation of brownian motion is just t at time t
brownian motion has had exactly t quadratic
variation that's why this looks like the line
y equals x so even though we have the full force
of all the randomness of brownian motion going
on here we find that when we look at squares of
differences and add them up all of these different
sample paths look like this just a line so that's
another key property of brownian motion and it's
really cool that we can actually see it even just
with our you know finite simulation that's all i
have for today on brownian motion let me know if
you want to see more on this topic and as always
if you liked the video don't forget to like
comment and subscribe thanks see you next time